Hey, this is Cam,
your over 50 makeup teacher,
and we're gonna talk about three of
the biggest mistakes
that you could be making with your eyeshadow
with mature eyes.
So the first one being that,
especially if you have deep set eyes like I do,
or hooded eyes,
is taking a really dark colour
and placing it directly in the crease.
That only accentuates that deep crease,
and you can't see the colour anyway.
Instead, use a neutral shadow,
keep your eyes open,
look straight ahead,
and place it above the crease. Eyeliner,
build that color to the out outer corner for lift.
And then make sure in that lower lash line
that you're having it meet with the upper lash line.
Smudge it out for a softer look.
You can even use that transition shade
to add to that bottom lash line,
versus going from the outer to the inner corner
of the upper lash line,
and then the outer
to the inner corner of the lower lash line.
And your eyeliner doesn't need.
It just closes up the eye.
Using a shimmer underneath of the brow,
it just ages you.
Versus a matte color. And then
you can even put a little bit in the inner corner,
just to bring a little bit of light to the inner corner
so you can see
the difference between the first and the second one.
Let me know if you Learned anything.
Or maybe you just prefer one eye over The other.
Which is it